was born in nigeria
but moved with his family to ireland 20
years ago when he was seven
george as you know he was my big brother
he was my eldest brother he was the most
sociable most charismatic
person he was a protector but george and
kencho also struggled with mental health
issues
on december the 30th he went to a shop
near his home in west dublin
assaulted a staff member and produced a
knife
video shows him walking home followed by
unarmed police who ordered him in vain
to stop and drop the knife
when he got home he was confronted by
the armed response unit
we're not showing the most distressing
clip which appears to show the 27 year
old lunging at armed police
before being shot multiple times his
siblings were just feet away in the
hallway
and say they narrowly avoided being hit
by the gunfire
it was it was really hard to see to be
here to see our brother
in such a state we were scared for him
we were just so worried and when we
heard the shots we were scared for our
safety as well within the house me and
my siblings
[Applause]
it was the first time a black person had
been shot dead by the guardee the irish
police
leading to weeks of protests they
shouldn't have shot him
if they can restrain an irish guy with a
long sword if they can destroy him why
can't that
same action be passed down to george
but his family don't think race was the
key reason george and kencho was shot
i think the main issue here is there's
not enough training a number of
resources given to the gaidee
to deal with the vulnerable people of
society the irish police the gardee say
they employed a graduated response to
what happened here
and before opening fire used pepper
spray and a taser which were
unsuccessful
the family have confirmed this the
guardi declined to give an interview as
the shooting is being investigated by
ireland's independent police ombudsman
the nikencho family which has received
racist abuse since the shooting
has appealed for unity there is a
section of people that are maybe trying
to use this as a time to divide
us as a society as irish people and i
think we should remember that a life was
lost and this is a time
for us to come together and not be
divided
that call has been echoed by many others
i would hope that this was a freak
incident and an isolated incident and
that we
we won't see incidents like this again
it's absolutely imperative now
that we don't allow people who want to
divide us
to divide us the investigation continues
george nakancho's family wants his death
to at least bring about unity
rather than division across dublin's
different communities
stephen murphy sky news in west dublin